então é crucial ressaltar que os grupos
mais vulneráveis a complicações são
aqueles com doenças de base diabetes
hipertensão sin metabólica que é aquela
constelação de sinais sintomas
relacionados a alterações dos exames
principalmente aumento da glicose
aumento da triglicérides no sangue
aumenta a circunferência abdominal
aumenta a pressão arterial e outras
condições crônicas que enfraquece o
sistema de defesa essas pessoas são
propensas então devemos evitar essas
doenças com o estilo de vida com estilo
de vida saudável que eu tanto falo no
canal então entra aqui a medicina de
estilo de vida que não apenas reduz os
riscos Associados à doença mas também
fortalece o nosso organismo contra uma
variedade de infecções não é só o mon
hipóxia Mas qualquer outra infecção tá
inclusive aquela outra que a gente não
pode nem falar o nome aqui